I remember opening the door one night
and he's got his lighting at the back
there's just blood everywhere and he sat
at the back of the cell just going like
that and he's just going everywhere and
I'm thinking and obviously because
you're on nights you know the instant
thing there will be probably to open the
door go in but because you're a night
you can't you have to wait for an
officer in charge so I'm pretty much
just watching this guy cut himself to
ribbons
growing up I would say
stayed on a lot of criminal activity
that I saw a lot so literally a
situation of how can I come away from
that and that was literally by joining a
government kind of job okay I think I
was about 21 22. oh that was quite yeah
I was quite young different from you I
never had any intention of going into
the prison service I literally fell into
it as I was waiting for I was actually a
part-time fireman at the same time so
that was the career that I was wanting
yeah however my girlfriend's mum at the
time was a prison officer didn't really
want to do it if I'm honest but I just
thought you know what it's a career with
at the time a decent salary although
it's not as good now no yeah
um so that was my train of thought that
it was a backup plan strangely enough
the letters just kept coming through the
door and I was in there within I'd say
two or three months I think now you
could probably just walk in probably
yeah probably could
I worked at hmp Wonder have you heard of
that yeah yeah um it was a men's jail I
think it had about 1 500 something
um inmates there I was around loads of
different inmates from
people that probably didn't pay their TV
license to murderers to everything you
name it oh Spectrum yeah literally what
category was that it was so originally
it's meant to be a b but they had a
section within the gel that they sent
was a c right okay yeah but it was
basically a cat B uh I worked at
Lancaster Farms which probably around
about 1200 Lots I mean 21 year old Lads
we all know what they're like
um it was just absolutely Bonkers ma'am
even before you've had a cup of tea in
the morning you rolled around on the
floor with six or seven alarms yeah you
know and you're just thinking Jesus
Christ I've just got up for someone
who's not worked in a prison or been to
prison
you can't fully on well can't fully
explain the environment and how kind of
hostile it is but that's the job that
you join isn't it you know you have to
get used to it quite quickly yeah and I
think when you open them Gates the first
time and go on to that wing and there's
80 Lads 21 year old going absolutely
nuts the sound and the echoing the
shouting yeah yeah and obviously it's
your first time yeah you've got like you
said put on this Brave face I remember
the first time I walked onto the landing
and I had everyone whistling shouting at
me and The Landings I don't know if
you're did you have um just twos
right it literally went all the way up
and I just remember walking on and all
the guys looking over at me and I'm
having to do that like a catwalk I'm
having to literally walk down the
landing here in the whistling I miss
this that oh my god look this that and I
just had to put on his Brave face there
was one point when I first started I
said I can't do this this is too much
and it not just because of the the
inmates it was obviously the staff it
was just everything it was so it was
completely different to training I was
just like no I don't think I can do this
like looking back now I actually don't
know how no I even got through the time
that I did get through I'm not gonna lie
I used to go on
when I initially joined thinking what
the hell have I done here
I like the prisoners I would like I
actually got along with some of them
some of us like they were such decent
human beings and it's like how did you
even wind up here kind of thing I get
obviously it was a respect thing you
know I mean you helped me out I help you
out kind of thing you listen to what I
have to say I listen to what you have to
say if you need anything and if I can
obviously accommodate it
um then yeah then we can I think I think
there's a certain amount of that just
being a general prison officer because
if you look at the numbers game three
officers on a wing there might be me
there might be someone who's 50 odd an
older girl who's maybe up for retirement
there might be one man and there's 80
prisoners if you're not if you do not
create relationships or like you say
it's gonna go positive into that you
could be wrapped up within minutes you
can have all sorts done too I mean I
know one of the officers that I used to
work with was locked in
a cupboard an old hostage very simple to
do a numbers game and even when the
alarm Bell goes
because of Staff shortages you'd be
lucky now with three or four come
running through the gate and if you've
got a wing of 80 people going at it it's
still not the numbers
yeah do you do you think you were
treated differently as a female in a
prison for male prisoners
um
yes I know I feel like being a female I
feel like I could talk to them a lot
better like with a guy like even now
security with a guy and a guy sometimes
it's a bit like yeah of course yeah
you're looking me up but but don't doubt
to me kind of thing on that way worse as
it was I was a female it was more like
that come on like we know that I can
kind of calm them down do you think that
the job was affecting your mental health
in any way
yeah about you massive yeah I feel like
um at one point I think I'd even become
depressed probably from
not the job itself could we have
obviously a lot to deal with like people
cutting themselves and like all all of
that now I don't I don't mind blood if
I'm honest with you but when in that
scenario like people are like screaming
and they're crying that they need to see
this family member or that person or
this and there's only so much we can
actually do like we want to do obviously
we're good people we want to do more for
them but we can't cause it a situation
that they're in but I feel like my
mental state at one point was a bit up
and down and there was no one to talk to
and if you've actually worked in a jail
no one will understand like they say go
home and talk to your family you could
go home and say oh by the way Mom I just
saw someone tried to hang themselves
today and I also don't know that's a bit
but they don't actually understand
they've not seen it the pictures like
it's a repeat in your head or having
nightmares or and I don't think you
can't once you've seen something it's a
version of PTSD isn't it yeah you can't
um you can't obviously unsee and then it
becomes normal to you although I started
to go home and I'd become more of a
recruiter I'm quite a social person but
after a day kind of like like an a shift
or a 12-hour shift same as you I
remember on a night shift walking around
doing the pegging which is like checking
the cells every hour to make sure
everyone's all right to make sure
everyone's not hang yourself whatever
I remember opening the door one night
sorry the flap on the door and you know
when you kind of think I'm not just
saying that and he's got his lighting at
the back there's just blood everywhere
and he's sat at the back of the cell
just going like that and he's just going
everywhere and I'm thinking and
obviously because you're on nights you
know the instant thing there will be
probably to open the door go in but
because you're a night you can't you
have to wait for an officer in charge
Oscar one to come so I'm pretty much
just watching this guy cut himself to
ribbons
but it I mean it didn't affect me at the
time because you just get on like like I
said I've been in the fire brigade so
I've seen
a whole array of things
but I think about it probably more now
or when I finished and same with a shift
I'd go home and I'd act all day long and
I'd go home and I just wouldn't want to
speak to anyone as the time went on in
there I became
started to go under a little bit more
started to drink a lot more I go
overnight I put a bath on bottle of red
wine after the red wine have been done
before I even get in the bath yeah
um at the time is it no I think I was
looking back on it it was a stress
reliever it was to get to sleep
yeah yeah
and there's one prisoner that I was very
cool with the reporter I had with the
with the prisoner I felt like I was just
normal again like I was actually able to
talk about normal life inside of a job
yeah yeah yeah I actually did trust that
um I actually did trust a prisoner did
you ever think that he was doing it to
manipulate yeah did you ever get that
inkling no never got do you know and the
funny thing is
that person was known for manipulating I
don't know because I was young I don't I
don't know I don't know what it was
built the Rapport over months that way
literally that was my turning point and
then I became too close I would say to
that inmate
um yeah that she came too close to that
in me that's when like phone calls
started happening with the person and
then I just felt I honestly didn't feel
like I was working in the jail phone
calls was in what you with him yeah so
what I presume he had a mobile in jail
yeah so
um whether it was his or the persons or
however he got he got it and then I just
one thing led to another uh obviously
was friends who didn't do nothing inside
Joe or anything like that but it was
more like
I can find it in him how long was he
serving
how long was he serving I think seven
years so it would be half was trying to
get me a drone are you thinking right
he's got a year to do so he had about
two he had about two he had about two
and a half left so when one thing
obviously led to another by then I was
already in too deep like I didn't even
realize oh my gosh was he manipulating
me this whole time and then afterwards
obviously when I did get arrested and
everything
um because allegedly I was bringing in
um they said I was bringing phones I was
bringing in drugs I was bringing in this
but it wasn't any of that I literally
stepped into the jail and I had like fat
ship so it was class C so what I got
charged for was
um anabolic steroids classy okay um so
it was like fat strippers to lose weight
um to putting in the gym yeah that kind
of stuff so um they tried to link it to
him but obviously there was no link
because I didn't pass anything over I
didn't and obviously when I stepped in I
didn't hide it or anything I literally
just something I didn't yeah well no
yeah because I'll get onto that in a
minute yeah especially to like hide it
like oh my God I'm smuggling in stuff or
anything like I literally just had it in
my jacket do you mind quickly telling us
what were the things you've done like
well you smuggled right okay so
initially
it was mobile phones
into prison
um with a fairly large gang
um it then became
I mean the same packet the packages were
given to me I didn't have anything to do
with what was in the packaging I was
given a package I was basically a
transporter you know if for one of a
better word
now the the first couple of packages I
believed it was a mobile phone
and after maybe two or three
I mean I'm not Daft I can smell cannabis
I can smell you know it's fairly obvious
what's going on and then it became more
than just mobile phones it became
cannabis
steroids stuff like that even watches
sometimes I know it sounds really
ridiculous you know that's it becomes
stupid I've lost all kind of I mean I
know it sounds ridiculous but
I'd lost all reality at that point you
don't feel like you're in jail no it was
weird yeah even in my own personal life
I'd lost the grip yeah so that was just
an extension of that yeah so you know I
should have asked me to bring you a
packet of polos and I probably would
because I didn't my head was gone yeah
yeah I really appreciate that
in my mind mentally I qualified it in
the sense of I worked there say three
four years okay I reckon I was searched
properly I mean I'm not you know
obviously you get your Pat downstairs I
reckon I was searched properly twice in
that time
so when I was doing what I was doing the
mentality was I'm not going to get
searched I mean although I hid the
packages and whatnot okay
um we don't need to go into detail about
that but yeah
I I don't think there was a big risk of
me getting caught that way okay do you
know what I mean red-handed which is
actually what you're saying about just
walking through with it so I never got
searched the whole time I was there
never ever ever ever ever got searched
my scenario was
I'd been sat in the garden I mean I'd
been doing this now for a while I was
sat in the garden opened up that
newspaper middle page spread drugs are
prevalent in UK jails and it's got a
picture of Lancaster castle and one of
the lads who I'm involved with um
so I'm now thinking I couldn't believe
my eyes I was like oh my God and I was
on holiday at that point due to going on
an early shift on say the Monday I still
had two packages at my house and my
mentality then was right the game's all
finito everybody's on to you I
walked into the jail went past the two
doors where you see the signs if you
bring anything past this point you will
serve up to 10 years in jail walked into
the jail nothing untoward there was no
cars around there was only four people
in the jail at that point also I thought
um walk through the security gates like
I said before opened and it was the PO
on my wing so we said um much the same
as you can I have a word a minute I said
yeah no problem uh walked into the room
which was like a little room off the
corridor I had my little bag with me
sandwiches in
uh and he said and it was a man who I
really liked I used to play football
with him at dinner time I had a lot of
respect for him and he said I need to
ask you a question
I said right okay
now I'm thinking he's going to ask me
something about a wing and he said have
you got anything on you that you
shouldn't have
and I said
no no no
he said I'm gonna ask you again have you
got anything on you shouldn't have I
said no no
he said right okay you're gonna have to
come upstairs with me
there's a Northwest area search team
waiting for you I was like oh God here
we go and I knew the game was up then so
I walked up the stairs there was two
dogs
a couple of handlers three or four
different officers there was a governor
there and I just thought right it's over
when you guys got caught how how did it
feel
no when I when I got caught when they
well
when I first stepped in and then I
realized I was doing the searches I was
like oh my gosh what's going on I think
I've ever tried to put like one of the
the packages behind the Heat or relax
it's like gay away from me kind of thing
and after I was like my life's over
that's all I remember saying like oh my
gosh Brian call you I've Never Been In
Handcuffs I've never I've never been in
trouble like that I never even got
detention in school been in sitting in
handcuffs so I just remember sitting
there like yeah that will falls apart
they put me in the cell and it's like it
jumped from having that rapport with a
prisoner to now I'm sitting in a cell
with four walls still a full screw kit
on still had my I remember going to the
police station and I remember someone
who's like bro why is she here like she
meant to be on a view lot before I had
got out the Seoul the next day it went
around to all the gels
literally like you know that light skin
glove that did it it got around to all
the gels everyone knew before I could
even say anything that's when I finally
got it around my head okay I'm going to
jail
um so what in your mind what do you
think you would end up doing
realistically if you were oh probably
about two and a half three around about
them time it's like yeah because I
thought if she said to me you're gonna
look at four or five years I'm thinking
oh my gosh my life's overall like when
you hit five that's a long time lowest
do half it's still a long time
especially they've never been in trouble
so then and it's a license period I
found a license period afterwards
mine was seven years that's after
license so four years jail seven years
license that's a lot 11 years of your
life that you're under someone else's
like control basically and not even
having to like do anything about it so I
that's when I can get something done
with now yeah I didn't like the fact
that I had to wait a year just for them
to make a decision can you explain why
you ended up not going to prison what
was what was the whole thing with the
with it um I felt like I didn't go to
jail because of was he only got the
character references yep like for court
and everything obviously I was they said
to me when my solicitor said to me like
she was honest I went and I'm happy that
I had her she's like it looked about
four or five years
um they're gonna make an example out of
you yeah and I was just like what for
Class C like I was proper like Adam and
I went not guilty not guilty not guilty
I was like nope I didn't hand over
nothing you've got no evidence like I
was so like no like I'm not having it I
just couldn't get my head around that I
should be going to jail especially when
Ellen did it for financial game
joking aside I think because I mean this
is what got me through the actual jail
period I think
like I said I've become for two years I
saw Lads crumble in there you know hard
men big men experienced men I saw him
crumble for me for two years I didn't
not once I'd become a robot but I think
because we've worked in a jail
I already had the routine in my mind and
I already knew what my app and I already
knew what the system was I already knew
that I had to write on a bit of paper
too do you think that helped I think it
did looking but looking I mean I didn't
think at the time because my head was
mashed but on bail I was crying like a
baby like you said behind closed doors
after a couple of wines I'd be crying
like a baby thinking what of a dome what
have I done to my family what happened
to my life what have I done to my mates
yeah but I didn't kind of show it in
public
I think that's probably because you've
worked in jail and you're putting on
that brave face that you used to do with
probably the inmates yeah you probably
did it again after the situation
probably with your family and friends
and everything so the jail time was
exactly the same no emotion no nothing
after jail different cutlerfish it all
just went
probably could you hold it in for so
long as well whereas I think I've
mentally prepared I used to go to church
I remember going to church every single
Sunday
um with
the person I was in Jail's family even
okay yeah every Sunday and they kind of
helped me through
and they just said don't just give it to
God like things happen for a reason
there's a reason as to why you're going
and only till like I think two weeks
before my court case I kind of said you
know what accept it
but the person that I was
talking to he's actually my son's dad
now and so yeah we had a full-on
relationship outside lived together so
it wasn't manipulation that's what you
said it was actually um yeah it went to
a relationship had a child
um now obviously I picked up the
security obviously I do my own so after
the whole getting arrested I was like
what am I going to do like you think
your life's over kind of thing so I
literally started my own security
business
um cool P1 protection so it's literally
given everyone a chance because
obviously when you get a criminal record
as well of course it's hard to get jobs
and everything obviously you've got to
have a full-on Sia license and
everything but I cater for females that
have security work guys and everything
and I literally just turned my life
around I didn't let that hinder me
because like you said the license thing
it's like you're under this like a spell
like you can't do nothing you can't go
nowhere any job you apply for now it's
literally crb check oh my God yeah I
forgot and this time I've had this and
everything so and even after that they
contacted me to come back to the jail
because they needed staff for the
pandemic so really yeah so it's just
like you find Germany you want to get
rid of me you want me to go to jail now
that you see what I'm doing I've got my
own business and everything with
security and then now you offer me to
come back to the jail where you try to
send me no could you imagine them and I
know I know boys and girls that have
been in there and you'll know officers
the same
and I'm the same as you I look back now
and think I could have been in that job
for the next 20 30 years and I wonder
what kind of mess it would have met at
me I mean look at the mess it made of me
in three or four years the mental state
you might not have been able to function
properly there's so much different
things that it could have impacted you
so well there is that start about the
prison officers about when they leave
the job if they've done a certain amount
of stretch and working there within the
first two years it's really stupid to
high like 60 of people over a certain
age end up dead yeah because because of
their daily life is that fast-paced yeah
when they retire they sat at all
watching homes under the hammer and it's
something to be honestly the statistics
are crazy it really is yeah
one last question
looking back at everything you've been
through how do you feel about it do you
regret anything
do I regret anything
Looking Back Now I actually don't and I
feel like
that may be where I am today if I didn't
go through what I went through and to
see the turnover obviously with my
little one my business I don't think I
would have pushed myself so hard I just
got myself back up and I thought if I
didn't go through where I went what I
went through I wouldn't have the story
today I won't be able to
like um keeps people what I went through
for them to not go through because I
know there's so many offices still out
there that's probably feeling the same
thing and they ain't got no one to talk
to about it but I feel like for myself
it's made me a stronger person today
yeah so I don't I don't regret anything
I feel like I'm a better human
I do regret obviously I regret what I
did because it could have put people in
Jeopardy
um I regret
what it did to my mum and dad I regret
um putting myself afterwards put myself
through a lot of pain that's probably
the biggest regret because now I look
back and I think it was just an
experience yeah you did wrong yeah you
did and I'm happier now than what I was
then I would say to any young member of
Staff or new officer
if you're involved in that kind of thing
you need to understand I had a chance to
get out I could have added my keys in do
you know the day before I got caught if
I'd ever handed my keys in I wouldn't be
sat here saying the same thing so if
you're doing what you're doing or you
feel like you're going to do what you're
going to do you need to make your mind
up whether you want to stay in that job
or just leave it because there are other
jobs out there there are other
opportunities and don't feel trapped in
it
a member of fellow common in the middle
of the road machine gun
Bounce has been hit straight in the head
standing next to me I just remember all
the little youngsters like standing over
his body jumping over the bar